hallo leute hier wieder einmal wanne und
willkommen zu einem neuen look back
video rock band
ich glaube so spricht ganz aus oder
irgendwann irgendwann merkten lernen
heute gibt es wundervoll und zwar habe
ich eine bestellt und über für dollar
bestellt und man muss ja bei shooter ich
glaube 12 euro mindestgebühr irgendwie
so musste das erreichen der ziele waffe
12 euro machen lassen ich glaub schluss
kommen dass bei 5 bei warner bachl und
zwölf eure waffe ich weiß auch nicht
genau fest mit eiscreme und das noch
drauf ist nicht kraftlos und kinder -
und kurios und ananas und mango und
heidelbeeren und erdbeeren und toffees
ich keine ahnung was ich mir gedacht
habe
aber lasst uns anfangen ich bin sehr
gespannt und letztmals in der offenen
gärten hat war vor zweieinhalb jahren
oder so und dann habe ich super geil
aber wir waren vorher mittagessen und
wollten auch als nachtisch essen das
ging gar nicht also dieses ding ist so
riesig und fett und gut dass man das
duett muss das ist jetzt auch quasi mein
mittagessen
das muss ich meiner 12-jährigen
meinetwegen ich absehen apple mit 23 zu
mittag eine fette waffe mit eiscreme und
kicken geil abholen plastikbesteck es
blöd aber sonst also ein metallbesteck
ist ziemlich laut wenn man darauf auf
den teller knallt und das find ich doof
also der verzicht auf angst und das ist
bei einer recycelte plastikgabel also es
ist mit recyceltem plastik worüber
möchte ich heute mit euch sprechen
gute frage es gibt gestern nach erst
runterschlucken gestern nach wipperfürth
und zwar habe ich ja mein neues kabarett
hochgeladen und das ich glaube ich
mittlerweile schon das achte und habe
ich dann kommentar gelesen von max
mustermann ist auch mal ganz toll wenn
die leute nicht mit dem eigenen namen
sachen schreiben
ich blende es euch auf jeden fall hier
noch mal ein ja der hat max mustermann
sagt dass mein job ist weil das ständige
on off mit marvin sehr unkritisch ist
und die leute feiern ja die geschichten
werden
und welch ein zufall dass marvin dann
halt immer in wieder geschichte vorkommt
und was wir hier noch klar ja die
abläufe sind halt zum geregelt und was
passiert das wenn du einmal wieder zu
ende ist finde ich dann lustigerweise
oder durch zufall noch ein tagebuch und
das ist ja so eine sichere
einnahmequelle ohne schwach ist ein
system auftrag gegeben habe ich habe mir
gedacht war auch ist der genial
stimmt ich könnte das klappen könnte
jetzt einfach mein tagebuch durchleben
doch gleich noch zwei habe ich noch zwei
tagebücher
also das ist nicht so viel drin also
erwartet nicht so viel noch geht gerade
dem ende zu
aber ich könnte mich antrieb sind können
jetzt einfach selber weiter schreiben
und so tun als ob das echt wäre
und dann dachte ich mir sofort das heißt
ich müsste mich in mein zwölfjähriges
ich oder 13 oder so hineinversetzen und
sonne scheint du noch nie mit marvulli
ausdenken und ich habe definitiv besser
aus meiner zeit zu tun mir diese
liebesgeschichte mitmachen auszudenken
diese kommentare ich wünsche euch
gestern nicht ob ich lachen oder weinen
soll
bei dass sie versteht nicht oder
schrecklich und du max mustermann
das ist eine gute idee ich könnte das
alles fällt aber das ist nicht sinn
meines kanals ich denke hier nicht
selten tue ich nur im privaten bereich
wenn ihr versteht was ich meine
mango und gleich nach der mango noch im
topf
ich hab jetzt sehr lange keinen süßkram
gegessen
wahrscheinlich instant diabetes aber
nach heidelbeeren sehr gesund was ich
noch echt gut fand die reaktion auf
meine zehn arten euch zu sagen dass ich
wieder single bin video
ich habe wirklich erwartet dass ich
erwartet habe
ich habe gedacht dass da jetzt echt voll
wie negatives kommt wie ich das denn aus
trage und das unterscheidet los ist und
dadurch auch auf twitter mit einer
angeschrieben
ein bisschen diskutiert weil sie der
meinung war dass mein exfreund es besser
mit der öffentlichkeit vereinbart als
ich mir dachte mit man sich die
frechheit raus zu dir zu sagen wie du
mit etwas zu gehen soll
klar man kann schon sagen öffentliche
person nicht mehr der tabelle schon
jetzt oft genug gehört wird mich die
personen muss das mit den neuen teilen
und wenn du sowas zeit muss auch ein
witz aus und so aber das ist auch völlig
uns überlassen also vor allem wird mein
ex mann und ich halt auch ganz
verschiedene typen natürlich trage ist
das anlass mit öffentlichkeit aus als er
das hat aber nichts damit zu tun werden
besseren schutz oder wäre damit besser
umgeht oder woanders verstehe ich nicht
ein thema schiebe ich noch ein bisschen
vor mich herr viele haben gefragt und es
ist auch berechtigt ihr wollt wissen was
mit den katzen ist und ich sage das
jetzt ganz ehrlich und auch mit
weinendem auge mit dem lachenden auge
dass die katzen bei mein exfreund linken
mitte bleiben halt in meiner eigenen
wohnung bleiben sie und da habe ich mir
lange überlegt immer schwer weil man
sich zusammen haustiere holt na dann ich
meine gehören beinen da ist keiner der
mehr recht darauf hat aber auf meiner
wohnung auch bin ich ja schon also ich
wohnung gerade freunden und so und drehe
hier immer das passte alles auch ganz
gut um eine neue wohnung wird halt nicht
groß beziehungsweise nicht mal
ansatzweise so groß wie meine alte weil
ich mir auch für blöd es klingt aber
auch einfach nicht leisten kann also es
gibt nur über die sehr viel geld
verdienen das sehr schön aber ich gehöre
halt einfach nicht zu ich kann mir keine
wohnung leisten wo zwei ausgewachsene
katzen sich wohlfühlen und genügend
platz haben und ja aufgrund dieser
entscheidung habe ich dann auch einfach
gesagt dass sie halt nicht mitkommen
was mich super traurig macht vor allem
weil ich dir sehr sehr lieb habe aber
ich entscheide halt einfach ich
entscheide einfach da lacht am besten
für die zapfen ist und meine liebe
alleine wirklich glücklich machen wenn
sie kein platz um sich austoben haben
man bei haus katz sowieso schon immer so
ein thema das man sagten nur in der
wohnung ohne draußen zu sein ist scheiße
jahr finde ich eigentlich auch da kann
ich die nicht meine wohnung und ich muss
ja auch da zu sein
nein es schmerzt das wollte ich noch
dazu sagen
sehr schön aus aber sehr viel
wo war ich denn jetzt mit katzen wohnung
ganzen wohnung zu wohnung ab so genau
jetzt schlagen wollte es ist halt wo das
ich kann meine katze hat besuchen gehen
weil nichts also ich kann einfach meine
alte wohnung gehen wenn ich mich vorher
anmeldet und sagen hey auch die polizei
kann ich gut kommen müssen die kanten
kuscheln sind quatschen passt alles
also es ist im guten auseinandergegangen
erfolgreich haben guten
auseinandergegangen sind die cartoon ist
für mich auf der welt also erhält
besuchen kommen das habe ich auch schon
zwei mal gemacht und mich hin und hat
mit ihr gekuschelt und spielt und dann
gibt's kein problem
ich werde natürlich vermitteln wirklich
wohl jetzt schon zwei wochen nicht mehr
zu hause und ich vermisse sie
und wer mir auf instagram folgt und
meine instagram stories anguckt sieht
dass ich in meiner neuen wohnung
darmstadt ohne auch eine katharsis
und ich bin schon ganz cool wie hat
klaus und ist ein mädchen das beste
überhaupt
aber es ist nicht das gleiche
thomson henry sind wie cola form richtig
coole katzen
du bist nur wurde womit cup war die
arkona wenn einer von euch eine wohnung
in berlin hat und sie nicht braucht
meldet euch hier
und ich will dich so anstrengend eine
wohnung in berlin zu finden
ich meine das ist nichts neues so aber
diese machen besichtigung hätte jedes
mal das kochen
weil du also ich habe mich schon auf
habe ich noch eine wohnung geworben und
obwohl ich hätte mal ein schreiben der
youtube-star bild hallo ich bin im tor
bitte geben sie mir eine wohnung habe
mich schon auf eine wohnung geworden und
hab mir glaube ich schon
ich glaub ich hab mir schon sieben
wohnungen angeguckt
und ich bin grad nicht ich bin wirklich
nicht ich nehme das was ich kriegen kann
aber der wendigkeit wohnung angeboten
dann kommt wieder rein und es gibt halt
aus mittelmann man bezahlt geld man mit
zeit geld und erwartet doch dann auch
irgendwie dafür etwas zu bekommen doch
nicht kaputt ist und nicht als bedürftig
ja wann saniert ist doch mal ein bisher
nicht
die mietpreise sind eh schon so
bezahlten ändern
dafür hat man dach überm kopf hat ja
schön kann er doch bis die wände haben
und einen fußboden hier die ganzen
früchte
die man gar nicht geschmeckt schnellen
oreo kekse auf
wegen freunde früchte geil
ok ich merke ich werd ich habe hier
keine schokolade am mund und zu trinken
gibt es heute eine coca cola light denn
zucker total schädlich für den körper
leute 40 darauf zucker ja ich habe schon
gleich richtig aufgedreht sein
sie haben gefragt dann kommt das nächste
buch open video erhebe geschichte wann
kommt das nächste schmeckt das kommt bei
da ich keine küche habe beziehungsweise
keine eigene habe ich noch nicht
geschafft mich irgendwie kosmetik
aufkochen vorzubereiten
und ich suche gerade also ich habe
gerade mit ihm gesprochen der küche hat
ruhig wahrscheinlich drehen kann
also wird es auch ein
wie schmeckt geben zu einem gericht was
viele von euch wollten
ich mache eigentlich nur gerichtet also
ich hab eine große liste an sachen die
ich kochen möchte da aber sich für viele
leute immer etwas spezifisches wünschen
und das ziemlich viel also fangquote von
petterson findus habe ich ständig
gelesen oder es gab noch kein bürger da
wir ja die bunten bürger gemacht gab
schon zu oft auf youtube also wenn du
wie macht bei der camberger eingibst
gelingt durch 20 städte und buntem
ergebnis gesehen
es ist nicht schön noch ein topf mit
eiscreme
ich fühl mich wie auf einer
geburtstagsparty kennt jedoch noch von
früher
dieses gefühl wenn ihr die jetzt kuchen
und alles zwischendurch für gegessen
habt und dann dafür aber nicht
weggeschmissen dann macht euch keine
sorgen und klickt hier christoph wer
hier immer so rumläuft wer hat schon
gesagt dass er den rest auf essen wird
und das gebe ich ihm dann gleich
kanadier haben waffe jetzt wo wir
einfach mal niveau miteinander sprechen
gibt es etwas was ihr auf meinem kanal
gerne sehen wollt oder beziehungsweise
was gefällt euch so am meisten findet
ihr weniger gut
das finde ich eigentlich ganz wichtig
dass ich das meist von euch auch noch
mal so höre
denn sie macht alles also ich bin
zufrieden mit dem content object den ich
auf meinen kanal hochladen also ich habe
sachen wie du egal wie da kann ich halt
immer mal wieder was machen wo ich nicht
soviel quasi so mit kritik muss also ich
muss am ende dazu animieren aber nicht
so da muss mir immer etwas neues
ausdenken sondern etwas was ich immer
weitermachen kann weil sie schmeckt zum
beispiel venedig ist einfach so sachen
auszuprobieren supergeil
und natürlich um zwischendurch halt so
was wie youtube agents musste ich
einfach mal video idee die ich lustig
finden aus und machen einfach mal okay
ist was gibt's auf ihr mehr sehen wollt
habe ich überlegt wo diese kommentare
kommentieren halt das wieder
regelmäßiger zu machen aber ich weiß ich
auch nicht ob das noch machen einfach
machen das beste
geht's gut im leben nicht mehr noch eine
sache die gerne ansprechen würde
wie kann ich nicht so viel darüber sagen
aber ich wollte sagen dass jetzt viele
dieses jahr passiert was mich sehr
freuen
wo ich sehr viel herzblut reinstecken
paar sachen die sich verändern und ich
bin sehr gespannt darauf wie das so bei
euch ankommt beziehungsweise das ganze
jahr so mit sich bringt
ich glaube 2017 wird schon ziemlich cool
[Musik]
die 1 million abonnenten schaffen wir
die sehr locker ich finde immer so
bleiben ihr schreibt dort mehr
abonnenten verdient die braucht viel
mehr abonnenten
das war noch nie so viel auf einem kanal
also wer mich länger verfolgt der weiß
dass es seit zweieinhalb jahren hat den
hier macht aber niemals den nach oben
weil ich glaube ich einfach nicht den
content dafür mache dass ich wirklich
wirklich die decke starte ich kann jetzt
anfangen
jüngere leute anzusprechen aber auch das
also nein ich bin ihr jungs sahen die
zuschauer ein problem ich habe damit
wirklich jeder war mal jung und ich find
jungen sein cool und auch wenn ihr es
seid und nicht zu viel vor dem handy und
so hängt alles gut nur ich glaube ich
erreiche nicht so viele junge menschen
wie jungen menschen die ich erreiche die
sind immer so wie ich damals wirklich
immer sie erinnern mich mal also die
kommentare von den jungen leuten
erinnern mich immer stark sondern mich
selbst ich weiß nicht gebucht wisst ihr
eigentlich was ich für ein gestörtes
kind war aber ich war gleichzeitig auch
mal sehr herrliche wachsen aber so
kardinal ist toll was sie an deutschland
und dafür gut ich mag die leute nicht
immer den weg gehen den andere gehen
sondern ihren eigenen weg finden weil
eigene wege sind gut die sind toll ich
habe was eigenes aber man muss sich
immer auf zwang individuell sein wenn
wir etwas mag dass alle anderen mögen
denn das ist auch gut ich mag zum
beispiel gegen rucksack diesen ferien
oder so mit dem fuchs hinten drauf und
hab ich über der stadt gesehen
man habe ich mir ein geholt und jetzt
wenn ich damit der stadt herumlaufen wie
ich halt erstmal so ok alle tragen aber
zu tief für mich ein bisschen seltsam
aber mir gefällt er immer noch auch wenn
ihn alle tragen und eigentlich habe ich
dann auch nicht mehr zu erzählen heute
wahrscheinlich wenn ich gleich die
kamera ausmache dort fällt mir ganz
viele 61 für jahr das hätte ich noch
fahren können einfach folgen geplant
aber dann habe ich spaß fürs nächste mal
und ich hoffe ihr werdet mir dann wieder
gesellschaft leisten beim essen und
vielleicht holt ihr euch dann selbst
auch zu essen wenn jetzt mit e schon
getan habt denn das macht doch spaß
zusammen zu essen
aber es nicht so viel wie scrum das
macht euren körper kaputt
zucker ist giftig denkt dann sogar ist
giftig und das klingt ganz schön hart
arbeitet wo sogar ist giftig niemals zu
viel zucker essen macht euer kopf kaputt
und euer herz und macht euch schlau und
so karotten sind gut paprika zucchini
aubergine tatsächlich ahnungslos oder
paprika einfach um sie zu schälen ich
verstehe nur ab und an wie ein apfel hat
superviel wieder wenn sie denken wenn
ihr krankheit bekanntheit irgendwie und
paprikas essen das ist für mich immer
die mörder kombi und werde ich niemals
ich war dieses ja auch nicht krank
vielleicht liegt an paprika und ingwer
tee
man weiß es nicht und jetzt rede ich ein
schönes stück also bis dann
ok